hello Lex I'm wondering if you recall  what was the initial spark or  inspiration that drove you towards work  in AI was it when you were pretty young  or was it in more recent years so I want  to become a psychiatrist I wanted to I  thought of it as kind of engineering the  human mind by sort of manipulating it I  thought that's what I thought of  Psychiatry is by using words to sort of  explore the depths of the mind and be  able to adjust it but then I realized  that psychiatry can't actually do that  and modern psychiatry is more about sort  of bioengineering as drugs and so or  sort of I thought that the way to really  explore the engineering of the mind is  the other side is to build it sort of  and that's also when C++ really became  the cool hot thing so I learned to  program at 12 and then never look back  hundreds of thousands of lines later  just I love program I love building and  that's to me is the best way to  understand the mind is to build it  you